i have a goal and an interest in
ambition to unite our country
if this is what the people want i will
do that
[Applause]
if joe biden runs for reelection if
donald trump runs for re-election
oh man they're going to have some
competition
no i'm not talking about kamala desantis
cruz
holy whoever anybody who's going to run
i'm talking about the real competition
can you smell what the rock is cooking
there's a part of young rock
as if you're running for president in
2032.
a lot of people are reading a lot of
things into that well let me take
another drink of taramana before i
answer that one
it always helps with the answer i have a
goal
and an interest and ambition to unite
our country if this is what the people
want
then i will do that and this goes back
to me wrestling
in flea markets and used car dealerships
and even in that as as small and as
intimate and as rowdy as those crowds
were willie i still
had my finger on the pulse of the people
and i always got an idea of what they
wanted
in that moment so i say that to say like
if the time comes
where there is a good amount of people
who want to see that happen then i'm
going to consider it
how will you know if the people are
asking you to take that step
i think you would do deep dives of
polling and things like that and what
the people want will lead and inform
that decision
and if it is in fact what they want then
i'm going to take another drink of my
tarmana and i'm going to say okay let's
do it
tara mona terra mona taramana you gotta
give the guy credit for being
a an a-list salesman he's pushing this
tequila that he's
he's using which raises questions about
uh this tequila that he owns rather it
raises questions about whether or not
he's serious about running
is he just using the buzz of the
president thing
to sell tequila he's got a big terramana
sign behind him he opens up the answer
talking about ceremony he closes the
answer talking about tara mana
so maybe this is what people said about
trump for years they said oh he's just
trying to sell his
brand he's trying to sell his neckties
he's trying to sell
his memberships at his golf clubs he's
trying to sell us
the apprentice whatever he's just
pretending to run for president
so that he can do this i'm sure that the
rock realizes first of all i'm sure he's
paid attention to what trump did
and realizes that it is a good strategy
and it can help you
as a matter of business but also the
rock has floated this for years
he has been floating the idea of running
for president for a very very
long time and he has dipped his toes
into politics for a while he was sort of
a moderate he was considered a moderate
republican
he endorsed biden and harris in
2020. so i don't really like the rock i
don't think i would vote for the rock
his politics i don't think are my
politics
but i also don't like his answer i think
this answer is
everything wrong with politics
would you run for president well i'd
just have to poll
i'd have to take a lot of polls would
you run if the people want me to run
okay we hear that kind of silly jargon
there's
silly propaganda you know from from
candidates a lot
i would only run if i were called on to
do it and i would reluctantly
accept but but the rock actually takes
it further he says i would just pull and
i would pull
and i would pull and then if more people
wanted me to run than didn't want me to
run
then i would run that's not leadership
that's not what people want that is
actually bad politics
people don't vote for you because you
just
say you'll do whatever they want people
vote for you
because you stand for something i
remember this i remember this in middle
school
student government elections you'd see
some people get up there
and seriously 11 12 years old they get
up there and say i'll do whatever you
want me to do just please elect me
and and the the thinking a very
shallow political thinkers is oh if i
just promise to give the people whatever
they want
then they're more likely to vote for me
but actually i think they're less likely
to vote for you then
because it just shows that you don't
stand for anything you don't believe in
anything
the rock's whole pitch his whole
political pitch is i'm a centrist
i'm a i'm a ma i'll just do whatever
whatever 50
plus one want to be done that's what
i'll do oh so you don't stand for it
you're a big tough guy
you're extremely charismatic you're very
good looking you're very famous you're
very rich
but you don't stand for anything why on
earth would i vote for you
i'd be more likely to vote perhaps
for an honest democrat because at least
i know what i'm getting i have no idea
what i'm getting with the rock
the rock might end up being much further
left because he's just going to go
wherever the wind blows
really really bad pitch hey stop right
there
you before you go need to ring that bell
i know what you're thinking michael
michael
the decision of whether or not to ring
that bell it's a private decision
that i should make and me alone no it's
it's public buddy
it's public because we put these videos
out and then you might not get the
notifications
so you've got to do it i'm telling you
go ring that bell
subscribe like we'll see you next time